[Música]
rusia se porta en automóviles maquinaria
industrial tontos industriales aquí
nadie aparte de vehículos la famosa
skoda que creo que también llegar a
muchos a australia pero la las
consecuencias más temidas económicas son
por supuesto por el precio del gas y del
petróleo
ya somos muy dependientes de como gran
parte de europa hago como toda europa
prácticamente somos completamente
dependientes de bellegarde personas de
rusia que además pasa por ucrania
entonces pues se prevé que esto aunque
el cheque tiene unas reservas de gas muy
grandes y no se notarán inmediatamente
se sabe que esto se terminará pagando
con un incremento de los precios en
general porque cuando como todos sabemos
que nos sube el precio de los
combustibles sobre el precio de todo y
también ahora tenemos un problema en la
república checa- de inflación muy grande
ahora en enero fue de un 10 por ciento
por ejemplo interanual no la inflación
pues se piensa que esto precisamente no
va a ayudar sino todo lo contrario
[Música]